l'ambiance est détendue pourtant dans
quelques heures florian la cat et arthur
rinderknecht joueront sur les courts de
roland garros c2i vinoy de 22 ans
bénéficié d'une invitation pour jouer
sur ce tournoi du grand chelem en double
et première pour un joueur du
département depuis un certain michael
llodra
on est très chanceux d'avoir eu cette
fois le cardan doublé et je suis
vraiment impatient de vivre pleinement
cette expérience de mon premier roland
garros c'est génial c'est top
carter ont forcément on s'y attendait
pas forcément mais mais c'est vraiment
un super cadeau on va essayer de se
concentrer à 100% pour pour en tirer le
meilleur
les deux tennismen qui dépasse les 1
mètre 95 ne sont pas venus pour faire de
la figuration porte d'auteuil
les deux droitiers ont déjà travaillé
sur leurs points forts et leurs points
faibles pour préparer ce rendez vous je
dirais concerts tous les deux très bien
donc devrait être plutôt assez solide au
service mais c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
forcément les meilleurs retourneurs de
du monde donc on va s'étonner en service
et de briques et une deux fois de temps
en temps pour gagner quelques matchs je
pense qu'on est assez complet
on se connaît depuis qu'on est plus
petit on a joué ensemble pas mal de fois
donc je pense que notre force avec la
cohésion d'équipé et la bonne entente
premier match pour ce duo yvelinois ce
mardi 29 milles contre la paire australo
georgienne john millman nichols basij
billy la rencontre est à suivre à partir
de 11h du côté de la porte d'auteuil